un texto que genera un descontento a
gran escala según El Ejecutivo el
objetivo es restablecer el equilibrio
financiero del sistema de pensiones por
lo que propone las siguientes medidas la
edad legal de jubilación pasará
gradualmente de los 62 años actuales a
64 en 2030 es precisamente este punto el
que causa mayor descontento veo a mi
alrededor en muchas profesiones que hay
gente que está completamente agotada
incluso antes de los 60 años entonces
qué pasará si ampliamos el límite de
edad a los 64
los trabajadores nacidos a partir de
1964 tendrán que cotizar 43 años en
lugar de 42 para jubilarse mientras que
la edad máxima de jubilación para las
guerreras incompletas se mantienen 77
años para una pensión completa el
gobierno afirma que la reforma tiene en
cuenta la realización del trabajo en
circunstancias excepcionales pero una de
las críticas es que el texto castiga a
las personas con trabajos penosos porque
les será más difícil trabajar más tiempo
en el transporte hay transporte pero
también hay mudanzas hay muchos trabajos
en los que hay mucha manipulación es un
trabajo duro se imaginan a un trabajador
de mudanzas a sus 64 años bajando un
piano de un cuarto piso no es concebible
la reforma de las pensiones también
prevé el fin de los regímenes especiales
que benefician a los trabajadores de
algunas grandes empresas públicas como
las Industrias eléctricas y del gas O el
banco de Francia el gobierno también
quiere crear un índice sobre el empleo
de las personas mayores un dispositivo
para controlar la situación de los
trabajadores al final de su carrera en
las empresas según El Ejecutivo el
beneficio de la Reforma de las pensiones
se ha estimado en 17,000 millones de
euros en 2030